let's get more analysis now on the
situation in ukraine joining me is
former british army intelligence officer
and chief executive of mackenzie
intelligence forbes mackenzie good to
see you for as well as sally lockwood
our correspondent in kiev was saying the
ukrainians have now withdrawn from uh
lissy shanks uh what will the ukrainians
be doing now as they try and regroup and
also what is russia's next target the
ukrainians at the minutes will be moving
back to a line um it's a road to the e40
and it really joins up slove sloveyansk
and back and back here
um
there's some elements behind by the
ukrainians and whether they left there
on purpose or not but certainly they'll
be slowing down the russian advance
and that will allow the ukrainians time
to get back into their next defensive
positions i would assess they're already
pre-prepared because it was silent over
the weekend from the ukrainians it would
therefore make sense this was a planned
operation
um
intelligence indicates it was successful
in achieving the aims there will be
pre-prepared defensive positions and
those that have been in contact from
ukrainian sides will now be reconstitute
reconstituting in the rear echelons
the russians though in the short term
they've worked hard for this ground
and to take leicester chansk um
there has been
tens of combat units have been committed
to this the ukrainians have been
successful in making the russians fight
and kilometer by kilometer
so therefore there's nothing a process
of the russians putting together their
combat
capability that's they can meet the
medium term
and their operational long-term goal is
of course they don't the
the
moving into the donbass
how quickly can they do that it may take
six weeks for them to get in a position
where they can move um but we'll start
seeing activity now to the north of
slovensk and to the area of bachmat as
well whether they're attacks in force or
attacks more in a kind of probing effect
we'll see the next couple of weeks so
six weeks just to regroup before they
even begin the offensive then i would
assess that that to be that to be the
case you know they've got to think about
munitions they've got to think about
fuel they've got to think about food
they've got to think about their their
own
um people on the ground the morale of
those people and there's a lot to a lot
to be done yeah president zielinski um
has said that he
wants to retake land that has been uh
lost to the russians but he'll need more
weapons in order to do that what's he
talking about
yes he's talking about um the artillery
pieces are now coming into action the
caesar system a 155 millimeter um
artillery piece from the french and
brought into action the himmer system
which we see here this is the japanese
um type from the us the us have donated
eight of these in total four are in
action and the other four to come in a
couple of weeks time and i would assess
they need a combat mass of 54 to have
real effect
um they can fire
six rockets at any one time be in action
in 16 seconds they can shoot they can
scoot they can survive it's the type of
munitions that um the ukraines will need
in order to deter and defeat the
russians in the
coming months this piece here was used
at the
um on the second of july um an airport
in the in the military region and had a
lot of equipment on it from the russians
we understand yesterday on the third uh
this weapon system was used against
those um those those those aircraft so
starting to come into action now but
will take a period of months uh to
commit properly okay uh forbes uh thank
you as always